newsome goes out and does a press
conference for like i don't know what it
was at the dodgers stadium i don't know
if you guys saw this one out a couple
days ago i don't
we didn't put it here put newsom best
place to do business in america
he said california is still the best
people said what the hell is this guy
talking about is he smoking something
he's just tone deaf he says california
is the best place to do business
in america just type in news go to the
state of the state address
where's this news actually can knew some
state address generals
yeah he said there was a state of the
state anyways you have to really look
through it
and you would see best place to do
business search for it best place
you know there's a long-term yeah he
said business just type in business
put the keyword business well has the
most innovation venture capital small
business in the country we will keep
fostering every smaller certainly
drivers of gdp
so we build uh special taxes about
nothing not our families our small
businesses
you know governments are about to covet
boom there's only providing small
business
you'll find it if you keep looking for
it you'll find he says california's the
best place to do business
what does it say the special mix of
audacity human capital and creativity
founded in california means there's
literally no better place to do business
audacity is a great word it's the
audacity can you imagine
it's the audacity of sacramento to tax
and regulate businesses and he uses
you know it's our audacity to be
entrepreneurs and stuff you know
anything about entrepreneurs you got the
audacity to tax and regulate and chase
them out i mean let's speak it and look
he was talking about
we have the ability to create the
california for business and jobs and
everything
you know what he sounds like he sounds
like tennessee
right we have the ability to build this
wait you did build it you were the
golden state you were
you know california put the man on the
moon screwed up yeah you
you fumbled the opportunity we have the
opportunity to create this what's with
the vision somebody told them hey
your speech has got to have vision a lot
of vision a lot of vision you know you
have to be positive you got to be
assertive you have to show leadership
and vision
and then everything you say now is going
to you're going to get meme to death
this guy already has 1.9 recall votes
and they say 30
of them are from moderate democrats and
what did yahoo news say what did yahoo
say about him
and florida oh yeah that a closer
inspection california actually did
better than florida did on the covid
thing and then yahoo news picks up like
two sets of stats to put in there that
did show a reflection but what are they
really doing it's yahoo news and
liberal media supporting their guy the
guy that wears their jersey
you know i think and i'm trying to pick
on florida and desantis a little bit
because he wears the other jersey
i'm not sure if you understand though
tom cause uh francisco and fresno he
received five thousand dollars to reopen
his pastry business
after being closed for six months i mean
he's he's sad he's good
no sarcasm by the way what kai just read
newsome actually said that are you
cringing
is anybody else cringing that's why he
said it that's why it's so pathetic
right when i was looking at this i'm
like you gotta be he said this two days
ago and i'm like oh my god that's a case
do you know how many we are we are still
25 to 30 percent of the state of
california
i cannot tell you how yesterday i had a
call with a couple that
chris and mary had a call with them you
know the caller had uh sam uh
we were setting up chris and mary the
zoom i was doing and i'm talking to them
they're from san diego they've been
there their entire lives they love san
diego they don't want to go anywhere
else they've never lived anywhere else
you know what she said she says i'm
worried they have they have i think
seven kids
i'm worried seven kids i said why are
you worried
because i've never lived in another
place i've never moved to another place
i don't know where to go this is all i
know it's and i said i totally
understand i said for me
it's not a big deal because i lived in
iran i lived in germany i lived in la i
lived in south carolina i lived in
kentucky tennessee
dallas florida i'm good because if you
push me out i'm
going to another place i love america i
fight to make sure these freedoms stay
put because i don't want to go anywhere
else i would like to stay to stay in
this great i served in this country's
army
i love this place right what's the point
there
call-ins but we can't stay here longer
because
california is just constantly
challenging us
constantly making it difficult the other
day i'm driving on the freeway and i see
a guy
who's changing his tire i see a chp
giving him a ticket i can't say and he's
just going through all these stories
that he's telling me here
and you got a new sum going out there
telling a story about california is the
best place to do business
the reason why desantis and abbott are
winning is because of
ludicrous stupid statements being made
by a guy like that in the state of
california
okay that's why desantis and abbott are
winning
on paper with business with small
business owners
and a guy like that is being you know
destroying small businesses
and is thinking there's no way people
the pompous the arrogance
no one will leave california nobody will
leave california
look we've been around the block what
happens to arrogant people what happens
to them eventually you can't go around
walking around thinking your
infamous and somebody cannot not you
know you're you're so powerful that
somebody cannot touch uh knock you out
nobody's untouchable
nobody right is untouchable nobody
is untouchable nobody is unattachment
that includes the city california so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye